bonjour à tous Bienvenue c'est l'heure
de Parlement Hebdo bienvenue sur les
chaînes parlementaire à mes côté Céline
Bitner bonjour Céline bonjour Mel et
dans l'actu cette semaine après le choc
des attentats le gouvernement était
attendu sur les proposition des annonces
des moyens et des hommes l'arsenal
antiterroriste a été renforcé l'arme
parvient à sauver des postes
mobilisation également pour l'école
l'accent est mis sur la laïcité au total
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
seront engagés dans ce contexte les
Français apprécient l'action du couple
exécutif un bon historique pour François
Hollande qui retrouve des sommets
atteints avant son élection de 2012
manuel Vals gagne lui aussi des points à
gauche comme à droite et puis cette
semaine le président de la République
s'est adressé au parlementaires il a
anancer son plan pour la transparence de
la vie publique transparence pour les
élus pour la vie économique plus de
règles plus de vérifications alors pour
commenter cette semaine notre invité est
David Rachlin bonjour alors vous êtes un
peu un symbole un symbole car vous êtes
l'un des deux premiers sénateurs de
l'histoire du Front national plus jeune
sénateur de la 5e République à 27 ans
vous représentez également cette
nouvelle génération frontiste voulue par
Marine Le Pen et puis vous êtes aussi un
petit peu cumular puisque vous êtes
également le maire de la ville de Fréjus
alors je vous qu'on regarde ensemble
cette image regardez c'était le 1er
octobre 2014 votre premier jour au
Palais du Luxembourg et en tant que
Benjamin vous étiez secrétaire de séance
plusieurs sénateurs ont alors refusé de
vous serrer la main est-ce que ça se
passe mieux aujourd'hui au Sénat oui oui
écoutez les choses se passent très bien
j'étais pas de toute façon venu au Sénat
pour me faire des amis je suis là pour
défendre des grands électeurs qui m'ont
fait confiance qui ont fait confiance à
mon mouvement et qui considérait qu'il
était logique som toute que plusieurs
millions d'électeurs soient représentés
au Sénat nous ne sommes que deux
d'ailleurs et je pense que ça n'est pas
le reflet de ce que nous représentons
réellement mais il n'en reste pas moins
que depuis les choses se passe bien on
vous sert la main dans les couloirs oui
oui absolument la plupart il reste
toujours quelques secteurs mais peu
importe je suis pas là pour leur plaire
donc ça ne me dérange pas alors vous
connaissez le principe de l'émission on
va passer en revue tout ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine dans l'actualité on
va commencer par le lundi François
Hollande Emmanuel Vals on la
côte c'est un bon de popularité record
pour l'exécutif 21 points pour le chef
de l'État 17 points pour Manuel Vals il
récolte en fait les fruits de la gestion
de la crise qui vient de se dérouler
Jean-Baptiste
Daoulas le rebond est spectaculaire
d'après un sondage Ifop Fiducial pour
Paris Match la côte de satisfaction de
François Hollande gagne 21 points à 40 %
le président de la République n'avait
pas atteint un tel niveau de popularité
depuis février 2013 regain de confiance
également pour Manuel Vals plus 17
points le Premier ministre est à 61 % de
bonnes opinions un rebond lié à la
gestion des attentats terroristes de
Charlie Hebdo et de la porte de vincè
clairement les Français considèent que
franceand a été à la hauteur qu'il a
réussi à gommer les critiques
récurrentes en terme de manque
d'autorité en terme de manque de fermeté
en terme d'attertermoiement c'est
maintenant un président qui incarne
l'unionf nationale et qui a mis fin au
Holland bashing parce que ce qui est
absolument nouveau dans ce sondage c'est
bien sûr la progression de franç Holland
à gauche il gagne 30 points chez
sympathisant socialistes mais c'est
aussi et surtout pour la première fois
il progresse nettement chez sympathisant
de droite et du centre la séquence est
délicate pour l'opposition difficile de
critiquer François Hollande après de
semaines d'union nationale les bulles
spéculatives ont vocation un jour à
exploser donc nous verrons quand nous
reviendrons dans une période un peu plus
classique j'allais dire où les
Français regarderont leur leur sujet de
préoccupation quotidiennees tel que
l'évolution du chômage l'évolution de la
situation économique et sociale de notre
pays en 1991 François mitteran avait
connu également un rebond au début de la
guerre du Golfe mais cette lune de miel
avec l'opinion n'avait duré que quelques
mois alors David Rachine cette question
va peut-être vous surprendre mais
faites-vous partie de ces Français qui
ont changé de regard sur le président de
la République en tout cas on peut dire
que il est quand même normal que les
Français se solidarisent de leur
gouvernement en pareil situation et il
est vrai nous l'avons dit d'ailleurs
clairement que François Hollande a
plutôt bien géré ces moments éminemment
douloureux pour notre pays néanmoins
désormais il va falloir laisser passer
le temps du deuil et maintenant se
concentrer sur les v vitable proposition
dans notre pays a besoin pour pouvoir
prévenir ces ces menaces dramatiques on
va venir ça é un faute pour François
Hollande Emmanuel bals oui dans le cadre
de la gestion encore une fois de de ce
drame dans le cadre de l'hommage qui a
été rendu je crois à l'exception de
l'exclusion du Front National et de
Marine Le Pen de la fameuse marche il
n'en reste pas moins que globalement je
je considère qu'il est normal que les
Français se rassemblent autour de notre
pays de son gouvernement autour de la
République française et de ses valeurs
vous ne regrettez pas de pas avoir
participé à la marche fin cétait ouvert
on vous a dit venez Vienne qui veut mais
nous avons participé aux marches dans
les régions il y a pas que Paris il a
aussi moi j'étais à Fréjus avec plus de
5000 fréjuciens sur la place de la ville
sur la place de la mairie euh dirigants
la grande photo d'unité national tous
les dirigeants tous les dirigeants du
Front national tous les dirigeants du
Front national étaient partout dans les
provinces de notre pays je crois que on
ne va pas à une manifestation dans
laquelle nous ne sommes pas invités je
pense que c'est som toute logique et je
regrette qu' cette C occasion le
gouvernement a exclu 25 % des Français
en tout cas une responsable politique
majeure qui n'aurait pas dû être exclu
de mon point de vue l'une des seules
quand même personnalités politiqu qui
n'augmente pas qui stagne dans les
sondages c'est Marine Le Pen alors
pourtant sur le fond la la période
pourrait sembler propice aux thès du
Front national pourquoi ça ne profite
pas à votre parti vous savez nous étions
encore une fois dans la période du deuil
dans la période de l'hommage et c'était
bien normal vient aujourd'hui le temps
de la réflexion des propositions Marine
Le Pen s'est expprimé s'est exprimé
seulement il y a quelques jours vendredi
dernier je crois à l'occasion d'une
grande conférence de press isolé quand
même Marine Le Pen non non je crois pas
du tout encore une fois vendredi dernier
elle a commencé à s'exprimer sur les
propositions qui qui sont les nôtres et
dont on va avoir l'occasion probablement
de reparler et je crois que c'est
là-dessus que nous allons être jugés je
ne me fais pas de souci je vous signale
au passage qu'il y a eu un sondage dans
le Figaro il y a quelques heures pour
dire que 45 % des Français pouvaient
éventuellement voter pour le Front
national donc nous ne sommes pas si
isolé que ça le grand test pour
l'exécutif pour vous pour tout le monde
finalement de parti politique c'est quoi
c'est la prochaine législative partielle
qui aura lieu dans le dou c'est
là-dessus qu'on va juger si l'exécutif a
réussi ou vous savez les législatifs
partiel réagissent aussi en fonction de
considération locale et je crois pas
qu'il faille se concentrer là-dessus en
revanche la prochaine c'est pas un test
national pour la prochaine bon nous en
tirrons un certain nombre de
conséquences bien sûr mais ça n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga de ce qu'il faut
considérer politiquement aujourd'hui en
revanche la prochaine élection majeur
c'est les élections départementales qui
vont avoir lieu en même temps au niveau
national et là nous verrons
véritablement où on est l'opinion et je
crois qu'on peut s'attendre à de très
bons résultats pour notre mouvement bien
sûr alors ce lundi c'est aussi la colère
de plusieurs pays musulmans contre la
Une de Charlie hebbdo à Gaza en Iran
tcheni ou encore en Afghanistan des
milliers de manifestants ont protesté
contre la Une de l'hébdomadaire
satirique représentant le prophète
mahomé des drapeaux français ont été
brûlés au PAC Pakistan à Niamé au Niger
des Français ont été invités à ne pas
sortir de chez eux après des
manifestations violente alors est-ce que
Charlie Hebdo a bien fait de publier une
nouvelle fois la caricature de mahomé à
la Une ou alors est-ce que c'était une
provocation vous savez je crois que
notre République notre pays est attaché
à la liberté d'expression et à ce titre
Charlie Hebdo peut publier ce qui lui
plaît et ce qu'il a envie de publier
néanmoins effectivement ça a suscité un
certain nombre de réaction je crois que
par certains aspects elles sont
excessives mais nous ne pouvons pas
demander à tous les pays du monde
d'avoir les mêmes pratiques que nous
d'avoir le même ton dans les médias dans
la presse d'avoir cette même liberté
d'expression ce serait mieux si c'était
le cas ça n'est pas le cas nous devons
en prendre acte simplement mais faire
respecter en tout cas en France ce
principe clair de liberté d'expression
qui m'aparaît essentiel 800000 personnes
en chechenenie ça vous a surpris ou pas
la francecoup oui oui c'est beaucoup
indéiablement et je crois que les
gouvernements de ces pays seraient bien
inspirés dirait de rappeler que il faut
respecter les autres nations du monde
respecter la France pour ce qu'elle est
je pense que c'est un un point important
est-ce que c'est pas aussi le symbole
finalement d'une montée d'un un
sentiment antiançais dans le monde c'est
surtout la démonstration manifestement
d'une montée d'une
forme de radicalité dans la pratique des
religions et je crois que par certains
aspects nous pouvons nous en inquiéter
nous voyons ce développement faramineux
de l'islamisme radical
en Syrie par exemple en Irak aussi mais
pas seulement au Yémen et ailleurs et je
crois qu'il faut que là aussi nous en
tirions un certain nombre de conclusions
et surtout que nous protégions notre
pays contre ces menaces allez on arrive
au mardi manuel Vals emploie des mots
qui
fâchent c'est une formule choc lors de
ses vœux à la presse le Premier ministre
a dénoncé un apartid territorial social
ethnique pour décrire la situation des
banlieux une petite phrase qui a fait
bien sûr beaucoup réagir RIM
benamur près de 2 semaines après les
attentats du 7 janvier comment lutter
contre la division de la société
française comment rebattir une unité
nationale manuel Vals lors de ses vœux à
la presse dresse un lourd constat oui
ces derniers jours ont souligné
beaucoup des mots qui rongent notre pays
ou des défi que nous avons à relever la
relégation périurbaine les ghetos
ce que j'évoquais en 2005 déjà un
apartide territorial social ethnique
quelques heures plus tard le premier
ministre répond à François de rugis lors
des questions au gouvernement avec la
même gravité dire que pour ce qui
concerne l'école ou les quartiers ou le
sentiment de relégation ou de
serrégation dire qu'il faudrait résoudre
ces questions en quelques jours en
quelques semaines n'aurait aucun sens
nous répondrions d'ailleurs pas à
l'exigence des Français aux quatre
colonnes le mot d'apart utilisé par
Manuel Vals divise si on prend le mot
àart pour ce qui veut dire c'estd un
développement séparé des gens au sein
d'une même communauté nationale c'est en
partie ce qui est en cours en France la
politique de partartteil en Afrique du
Sud c'était une politique qui visait à
séparer les gens leur interdire
de leur mettre toutes sortes de barrière
dans la progression dans la société
c'est pas ce qu'a voulu la République
française Françis Hollande a chargé les
de sembl de réfléchir au moyen de
renforcer l'appartenance républicaine
notamment grâce au développement du
service civique les deux chambres ont
jusqu'au mois de mars pour faire des
propositions dire des choses fortes pour
être entendu c'est un peu la méthode que
vous aussi vous pratiquez au frond
national oui en choisissant les termes
que nous employons et surtout moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le fond des choses
qu'est-ce qui fait que nous en sommes
arrivés en effet par certains aspects
une séparation entre
communautésendrez je ne reprendrai pas
ce terme de on peut parler en revanche
de séparation dans un certain nombre de
cas entre les populations on peut parler
de communautarisme et qu'est-ce qui fait
que nous en sommes arrivés là c'est la
politique appliquée par l'UMP et le PS
depuis maintenant des dizaines d'années
ce sont eux qui ont malheureusement
amené ces revendications communautaires
à être exaucé ce sont eux qui ont
produit cette situation et je crois que
on ne peut pas eu c'est une erreur de la
part du Premier ministre le mot vous a
choqué le mot d'apparide il est assez il
est assez choquant mais ce qui est
encore plus choquant encore une fois
c'est de voir manuel Val aujourd'hui
dénoncer une situation qu'il a avec ses
amis umpeps d'ailleurs lui-même créé et
je crois que c'est cela dont il faut
parler mais alors vous-même j'ai
regarder un petit peu les chiffres mais
dans votre ville de de fréjut vous avez
réduit et bien les les subventions aux
associations est-ce que ça ça ne
provoque pas de fait une gettoisation
des des quartiers non vous savez à
Fréjus j'ai simplement fait en sorte que
les centres sociaux fonctionne mieux et
en effet vous avez baissé de 50 % les
subventions pour les centes soci nous
avons mis fin à un certain nombre de dép
pense inutile et nous avons euh fermé
même un centre social pour en pour créer
à la place une maison de quartier qui
sera elle grâce au service jeunesse de
la ville grâce au CCS beaucoup plus à
même de traiter les différents problèmes
qui se posent à ce quartier mais de
manière générale je crois que avant
toute chose et avant toute problématique
lié aux centres sociaux et à la question
sociale il faut rappeler un certain
nombre de valeurs clair que sont
l'autorité la discipline qu l'ordre
quordre public qu est le combat contre
le communautarisme et je crois que ce
sont des valeurs qui malheureusement
n'ont pas suffisamment été rappelées par
le gouvernement et par l'État ces
derniers mois et ces dernières Ann
proposition de Malec boution a vu dans
le reportage c'est la la mise sous
tutelle de l'État de certains quartiers
vous seriez pour non non non je ne suis
pas pour la mise sous tutelle d'un
certain nombre de quartiers je crois que
les administrations locales et les
collectivités territoriales doivent se
gérer par ceux qui sont élus pour le
faire les maires dans la plupart des cas
sont à la hauteur de leur responsabilité
qu quel que soit d'ailleurs leurs étiqu
politique ça n'est pas la question ils
essayent avec des moyens toujours moins
importants à cause des économies
budgétaires qui sont fait justement par
l'État sur le dos des collectivités
territoriales de gérer la situation
qu'est-ce que vous proposez concrètement
alors pour éviter justement cette
gettoisation vous savez il faut lutter
contre le communatarisme de manière
ferme dès le plus jeune âge et je crois
que ça c'est éminemment important il
faudra aussi concrètement concrètement
ben lutter contre le communautarisme
c'est rappeler les valeurs de la
République c'est ne pas céder au revend
communautaire c'est ne pas permettre de
piscine par exemple mais par exemple et
les menus dans les cantines et tout ce
dont on a l'habitude de parler depuis
maintenant des années les burkas qu'on a
le droit manifestement en tout cas de
fait de continuer à porter il y a un
certain nombre de lois mais dans les fa
s'aperçoit que ça n'est pas appliqué et
donc c'est le respect total de la
laïcité encore une fois ça n'est pas
suffisamment le cas aujourd'hui et je
crois que l'UMP et le PS et
particulièrement ce gouvernement pte une
responsabilité majeure dans l'absence de
respect de la laïcité d'un mot juste
d'un mot sur le mot à partteille qui
était prononcé est-ce que là manuel Vals
a brisé l'unité nationale qui était en
cours mais de toute façon il est normal
que les débats dans une démocratie dans
la République reprennent mais l'unité
nationale n'aurait peut-être pas dû être
briser de cette manière-là avec ce
mot-là un visage a fait la une de
l'actualité ce mardi celui de Lassana
btily ce jeune Malien de 24 ans est
devenu officiellement français cet
employé de l'épicerie percach avait aidé
des clients à se dissimuler dans la
chambre froide lors de la prise d'otage
de la porte de Vincen manuel Vals et
Bernard casazenuve le ministre de
l'Intérieur ont salué son acte de
bravoure alors vous qui êtes contre
l'immigration est-ce que l'assana batili
c'est pas la preuve que l'immigration
peut aussi être une chance pour la
France vous savez moi je suis pour le
contrôle aux frontières d'abord et pour
réduire en effet drastiquement le nombre
d'étrangers qui rentrent sur notre seul
car il en rentre encore 200000 par an je
crois que c'est beaucoup trop et que ça
n'est pas d'ailleurs sans lien avec la
situation de communautarisme qui se
développe dans notre pays mais dans ce
cas bien précis il est bien évident que
et et d'ailleurs moi je crois que la la
nationalité s'érite ou se mérite en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence il l'a
mérité c'est bien normal euh qu'il qu'il
puisse devenir français mais ça ne doit
pas être automatique comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et je crois qu'on devrait
être beaucoup plus raisonnable dans le
nombre de euh d'acquisition de la
nationalité7000 57610 personnes pour
être exacte en 2014 ce qui est beaucoup
moins que l'anné dernière ce qui est
beaucoup trop toujours parce que vous
savez nous n'avons plus les moyens de
cette politique nous n'avons plus les
moyens d'accepter l'arrivée sur notre
territoire de 200000 immigrés chaque
année je crois que la démonstration en
est faite que tous les politiques
s'accordent à dire que l'immigration est
trop importante dans notre pays mais
l'UMP comme le PS n'en tire pas les
conclusions et ne régule pas aux
frontières cette immigration là c'est
nous avons là en effet un vrai sujet ce
contrôle aux frontières qu'il va falloir
éétablir dans les plus BRFS délais on va
y venir justement sur les mesures contre
le terrorisme qui ont été prises par
Manuel Vals nous sommes
mercredi 15 jours après évidemment les
attentats qui ont ensanglanté Paris les
mesures étaient attendues manuel Vals a
annoncé un renforcement considérave des
moyens humains et matériels un plan
d'urgence pour lutter contre le
djihadisme le détail avec
c'est un gouvernement uni derrière son
premier ministre qui est venu présenter
l'ensemble des mesures pour lutter
contre le terrorisme un gouvernement uni
et entièrement mobilisé pour se faire
des moyens importants sont débloqués ce
sont 425 millions de crédits
d'investissement d'équipement et de
fonctionnement qui seront consacré au
cours des TR prochaines années à ce plan
de renforcement 425 millions d'euros
donc sur 3 ans pour surveiller près de
3000 personnes impliquées de près ou de
loin dans des filières terroristes une
enveloppe budgétaire qui permettra
notamment de gonfler les effectifs de
renseignement 1400 emplois rien que pour
le ministère de l'intérieur mais les
effectifs seront également renforcés à
la défense Bercy et à la justice
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la radicalisation 60 millions
d'euros seront mobilisés et 60 auoners
musul seront recrutés pour les
prisons un fichier placé sous le
contrôle d'un juge sera créé dans lequel
seront obligatoirement inscrites toutes
les personnes condamnées ou
judiciairement mis en cause pour des
faits de terrorisme c'est donc un
fichier spécial de personnes condamnées
pour terrorisme qui va voir le jour afin
de permettre leur surveillance quant à
la peine d'indignité nationale qui fait
débat le Premier ministre n'a pas
tranché il a dit ne pas vouloir agir
dans la précipitation et a confié aux
deux assemblées le soin de formuler des
propositions
complémentaires est-ce que les mesures
annoncées par Manuel Val sont
suffisantes pour lutter contre la menace
terroriste bien sûr que non et la
véritable question est pourquoi ont-ils
supprimé des postes de policiers et de
gendarmes dans les 10 dernières années
pourquoi les moyens des renseignements
ne sont pas à la hauteur ne sont plus à
la hauteur de la situation pourquoi
pourquoi avons-nous fait des économies
sur les moyens de l'armée depuis
maintenant plusieurs dizaines d'années
je crois que c'est ça la véritable
question et évidemment qu'il nous faut
renforcer les moyens de la police et de
la gendarmerie dans des proportions
considérables évidemment qu'il faut
renforcer les moyens de l'armée et pas
seulement faire cesser la baisse des
moyens renforcer les moyens de l'armée
qui est dans une situation aujourd'hui
euh où est-ce que vous faites les
économies à ministr y a des centaines de
milliers d'euros d'économies à faire si
vous voulez on pourra en rediscuter sur
l'immigration sur l'Union européenne sur
toute une série de sujets vous savez que
dansain SEM là les propositions en tout
cas de notre côté ne manquent pas mais
il y a des un certain nombre d'éléments
sur lesquels on ne peut pas transiger et
je crois que malheureusement pendant de
trop nombreuses années des économies ont
été faites sur ces postes là ça n'aurait
jamais dû être le cas maintenant
d'urgence il faut renforcer les moyens
je le disais de la police du
renseignement de l'armée parce que nous
le voyons bien c'est indispensable et
est-ce que sur le fond vous seriez
d'accord avec un patriotacte à la
française bon c'est pas exactement ce
qu'on y met à l'intérieur ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il va falloir forcé dans des
proportions considérables non seulement
les moyens que je viens d'évoquer mais
encore agir sur l'éducation agir sur la
justice pour lutter contre le
récidivisme et j'ai posé en ce sens une
question à la garde des sauts qui vient
de qui avait supprimé récemment des
mesures contre les récidivistes alors
que au contraire pas encore pas encore
mais j'espère que j'espère que j'en
aurai une bientôt dans tous les domaines
il nous faut il nous faudra agir
malheureusement c'est le laxisme qui a
triomphé que ce soit dans l'éducation
dans la justice c'est le laxisme qui a
triomphé dans tous les domaines trop
d'angélisme mais bien sûr et pas de
prise de conscience de la réalité de la
situation pas de prise de conscience du
développement que nous avons dénoncé de
ce fondamentalisme islamique qui se
propage dans un certain nombre de nos
quartiers et dans un certain nombre de
nos villes ça ne veut pas dire que tous
les musulm évidemment sont de dangereux
citoyens mais une petite partie font la
démonstration qu'ils sont dangereux et
nous devons mettre tous les moyens pour
lutter contre eux ça n'a pas été le cas
jusque-l malheureusement alors que nous
nous avions prévenu alors mesure d'ind
digignnité déchéances de nationalité il
a hasard du calendrier le Conseil
constitutionnel se prononçait ce
vendredi sur la nationalité d'un d'un
franco-marocain condamné pour terrorisme
déchéances de nationalité validé par le
Conseil
constitutionnel répondz c'est une bonne
nouvelle bien sûr qu'il faut des choirs
de leur nationalité ceux qui commettent
des actes graves et même ceux qui sont
des délinquants récidivistes et même
toute une série de gens qui n'ont pas
être sur notre territoire je crois que
c'est la pure logique nous devons
choisir ce qui on ne peut le faire que
quand qu'il y a la double nationalité
c'est ce que dit le Conseil
constitutionnel vous voulez aller plus
loin vous en tout cas si déjà on faisait
cela ce serait déjà pas mal et si déjà
ceux qui ont la double nationalité de
toute façon nous nous sommes contre la
double nationalité et nous croyons qu'il
faut choisir et qu'on ne peut pas que ce
principe de double nationalité n'est pas
n'est pas sérieux mais pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui ont la double nationalité
bien sûr qu'ils doivent être des chut de
le nationalité c'est une évidence
absolue et bien il faut prévoir un
renforcement du dispositif judiciaire
des peines qui soient plus importantes
aujourd'hui quand on a quand on est cond
digité nationale par exemple peu importe
les mots mais aujourd'hui sachez que
lorsque on est condamné à une peine de
moins d'un an de prison on ne l'a fait
pas parce qu'on manque de place dans les
prisons parce que notre dispositif
carcéral et judiciaire n'est pas à la
hauteur de la situation je crois que
dans ces domaine là il va nous falloir
travailler sérieusement et en tout cas
il faudrait que ce gouvernement le fasse
sur le plan militaire maintenant
François Hollande a tenu un conseil de
défense ce mercredi l'armée réussi à
sauver des emplois 7000 1500 postes de
militaires seront finalement épargnés
sur les
34000 supprimés est-ce que l'armée a
encore les moyens de ses ambitions et
les moyens de défendre finalement notre
pays entre les opérations extérieures et
aujourd'hui le plan Vig pirate renforcé
bien sûr que non et nombre de
responsables de l'armée se sont exprimés
à différentes occasions et ont tiré la
sonnette d'alarme nous-même depuis des
années moi au Sénat j'ai eu l'occasion
d'intervenir sur le projet de loi de
finance dans ces domaines là et nous
voyons ons bien que non seulement les
moyens ne sont pas à la hauteur mais
qu'en plus ils étaient drastiquement
réduits ces dernières années alors qu'au
contraire il lui fallu les augmenter ou
en tout cas les maintenir moi je crois
que il faut que les moyens soient
renforcés qu'il faut que l'État fasse un
véritable effort dans ce domaine-là
parce que nous ne pouvons pas en même
temps essayer de dire et de rassurer les
Français sur leur sécurité et sur la
situation notre pays nous en demandons
toujours plus à l'armée alors qu'ils ont
toujours des moyens de petitte question
très courte la loi sur le renseignement
qui est prévu pour mars vous la voterez
ou pas écoutez nous verrons ce que nous
voterons nous irons dans le détail pour
vérifier si si les moyens sont à la
hauteur de la situation ce qui est sûr
c'est que je suis partisan d'un
renforcement très important des moyens
et nous aurons l'occasion de faire un
certain nombre de propositions y compris
au Sénat d'ailleurs service Civic ou
service militaire service militaire
obligatoire service militaire service
militaire pour de trois pour quelques
mois mais évidemment que cette cette su
on n'est pas allé dans le bon sens et et
c'est indispensable jeudi c'est l'école
qui est en première
ligne la cité autorité citoyenneté trois
mots qui résument le plan de njat
valobelkassem pour réaffirmer les
valeurs républicaines à l'école
250 millions d'euros seront investis sur
3 ans les détails avec Marie bremo on a
laissé l'école la communauté scolaire
les enseignants devenir le réceptacle de
tous les mots de la société alors
qu'elle devrait s'en protéger pour
protéger chaque élève un constat d'échec
met la volonté de rectifier le tir la
ministre de l'Éducation a présenté les
grandes lignes de son plan pour remettre
les valeurs républicaines au centre de
l'école ce sont 1000 formateurs à guéris
qui seront formés sur la laïcité et
l'enseignement moral et civique avant la
prochaine rentrée scolaire
1000 inspecteurs professeurs
documentalistes ou chefs d'établissement
qui seront formés pour répondre aux
questions relatives à la citoyenneté la
laïcité et à la lutte contre les
préjugés une journée de la laïcité sera
désormais célébrée dans tous les
établissements chaque 9 décembre journée
anniversaire de la loi de Séparation des
Églises et de l'État tous les
établissements devront également
participer aux commémorations
patriotiques et mettre en place de
nouveaux rendez-vous la semaine de
l'engagement et la semaine de la lutte
contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme tout comportement
contraire à ses règles fera l'objet d'un
signalement systématique de la part de
l'enseignant au directeur d'école ou
chef d'établissement et ces derniers
seront invités à y donner suite
systématiquement voilà donc le volet
sanction de ce plan qui veut également
assoir l'autorité des professeurs
l'exécutif souhaite un recours plus
systématique aux mesures de réparation
et de Responsabilis
sorte de travaux d'intérêts généraux
pour les élèves toutes ces mesures
s'inscrivent dans le cadre d'un nouveau
parcours citoyen du CP à la terminale au
total 300 heures d'enseignement moral et
civique mais également au médias et à
l'information des mesures consensuelles
qui ont un coût 250 millions d'euros sur
3 ans est-ce que c'est le le bon moyen
de réaffirmer la laïcité à l'école où il
faudrait aller encore plus loin il faut
aller plus loin évidemment et je crois
je crois que c'est dès le plus jeune âge
qu'il faut lutter contre les
communautarismes et nous nous avons dit
pour démontrer cela qu'il fallait
rétablir l'uniforme euh à l'école nous
avons dit
aussi la Marseillaise chanter la
Marseillaise exû bien sûr ça c'est une
bonne proposition bien entendu les
signalements dont on parle qui vont être
fait au rectorat ça n'est pas suffisant
il faut convoquer les parents
systématiquement il faut signaler ça au
procureur de la République pas au
recteur même si ça n'est pas
incompatible signalement ça peut être
nimp mais dès le plus jeune âge parce
que c'est quoi le plus jeune âge pour
vous dès le plus jeune âge dès lors que
les enfants sont à l'école et qu'on voit
qu'il y a un certain nombre de dérives
il faut des signalement qui soient des
signalements opérants qui puisse
permettre une réaction de la part de
l'autorité publique de la part de la
justice éventuellement pas à l'égard de
l'enfant bien sûr mais à l'égard des
parents quand c'est pour les très jeunes
je crois que c'est très important on n
fera pas l'économie et malheureusement
je crois qu'on ne va pas assez loin
aujourd'hui dans ces domaines là donc un
manque d'autorité selon vous aujourd'hui
de la part du gouvernement laisser faire
au sein des écoles et il faut aussi
réapprendre dès le plus jeune âge
l'éducation civique il faut aussi
peut-être un petit peu de morale à
l'école aujourd'hui on sait que la une
partie en tout cas des enfants sortent
de l'école sans sans savoir parler le
français et c'est absolument dramatique
il faut donc renforcer les HE
responsabiliser les parents aussi plus
selon vous oui mais bien sûr bien sûr
qu'il faut le responsabiliser les
parents je vous en parlais à l'instant
et je vous disais que le signalement
doit être fris auprès probablement du
procureur de la République pour qu'il
puisse agir sur sur les parents et pas
seulement sur les enfants puisque ce
sont les parents aussi qui sont chargés
cochochargés euh de leur éducation et
ces dérives naissent aussi en partie à
cause d'un certain nombre de parents qui
sont défaillants il faut bien le dire
journée de la laïcité le 9 décembre
est-ce que vous veillerez à ce qu'elle
soit célébrée dans votre ville à Fréjus
mais moi je respecte les lois de la
République évidemment
et et lorsque ce sera voté puisque ce
sera probablement le cas alors comme
partout en France la loi de la
République sera respectée évidemment et
peut-être et peut-être même d'abord et
peut-être même d'abord dans ma commune
c'est-à-dire et ben écoutez moi je suis
favorable à ce que dans ma commune les
lois de la République soient respectées
ben donc peut-être d'abord avant tout
donc vous voirez également est-ce que la
laïcité soit toutes les lois autour de
la laïcité soient mis en place soit
misise en œuvre parce qu'elles existent
aujourd'hui je pense à l'interdiction du
voile des signaux religieux vous savez
les questions des mères voilé pour les
sorties scolaires comment est-ce que
vous appliquez ça chez vous bien sûr
mais nous sommes vigilants nous
rencontrre pas nous rencontrons pas
particulièrement de de problématiques
lié à cela à Fréjus en tout cas mais je
sais que nombre de maires sont
confrontés à ces
situations il faut que là encore l'état
soit au côté des collectivités locales
au côté des élus locaux pour leur
apporter une aide pour pouvoir traiter
ce problème parce que ça n'est pas le
maire d'une petite commune seul sans
moyens qui est capable de répondre à
cette à ces problématiques donc il faut
là encore que l'État accompagne les
collectivités pour faire respecter la
loi et je crois que là encore le
signalement et j'en termine des des
instituteurs et des directeurs d'école
est très important ils doivent
participer agir au côté des élus locaux
l'affaire kahusac et tennou sont passés
par là françois Hollande veut une
république plus transparente encadrement
des nominations contrôle des lobbyes le
chef de l'État a annoncé une série de
mesures pour renforcer la déontologie
dans la vie publique on écoute François
Hollande pour éviter que des manquements
ne soient connus postérieurement à
l'entrée en fonction des
intéressés il devra être procédé à des
vérifications avant toutes les
nominations les plus importantes je sais
aussi que les assemblées travaillent sur
des propositions par rapport aux
candidatures aux élections
ensuite les nouvelles règles
déontologiques seront étendu à tous les
acteurs publics fonctionnaires comme
magistrat des projets de loi seront
déposés au Parlement et seront bientôt
inscrit à l'ordre du jour enfin il
faudra encore rendre plus clair la
confection des lois et des règlements
pour un meilleur encadrement des groupes
de
pression les lois se multiplient pour
renforcer la transparence dans la la vie
publique et pourtant on a l'impression
en tout cas les Français ont
l'impression que c'est un petit peu un
vœux pieux est-ce que la République
exemplaire voulu par François Hollande
c'est pour maintenant c'est surtout un
peu tard parce que après le nombre
d'affaires qui s'est il faut bien le
dire multiplié depuis ces derniers mois
particulièrement au Parti socialiste et
ça ne sont pas les seuls d'ailleurs
puisque d'autres sont apparus au grand
jour par particulièrement à l'UMP je
crois que c'était nécessaire et donc
évidemment qu'il faut aller vers
davantage de transparence c'est une
évidence absolue mais il y a aussi à
faire dans le choix des hommes et les
mouvements politiques y compris leur
direction devrait peut-être être
davantage vigilant sur les gens qu'il
choisissent pour aller on peetourner la
question parce qu'au frond national
aussi il arrive d' avoir des affaires et
des histoires avec des avec des élus
lesquels par exemple j'ai plus les
souvenirs en tête vous savez très
bien c'est normal que vous en ayez pas
en tête parce que les affaires sont
extrêmement rares contraement contement
à contrairement à l'UMP à la différence
d'ailleurs que nous euh à la différence
d'ailleurs à la différence d'ailleurs
que nous lorsquil y a une problématique
avec un élu nous nous en séparons
immédiatement ça n'est pas toujours le
cas du Parti socialiste qui pendant des
mois a gardé monsieur kusac comme
ministre me semble-t-il il en est de
même pour tous les élus qui ont été
condamnés à différentes occasions madame
andriilleux était encore récemment
vice-présidente du conseil régional euh
en ce que vous préconisez c'est de se
séparer le plus vite possible de la
personne qui a commis une alors il faut
envoyer un message clair il faut que les
partis prennent les responsabilités
qu'ils écartent les brebis galeuses si
on peut dire et encore une fois il y a
un vrai travail à faire dans le choix
des hommes et des femmes qui nous
représentent et qui sont les
représentants de la République alors
j'ai regardé he j'ai cherché sur le le
site internet du Sénat votre déclaration
de patrimoine n'a pas encore été publiée
vous venez d'arriver mais est-ce que
vous pensez que voilà c'est ce genre de
de d'exemple ou de procédures qui
peuvent aller dans dans la bonne voie
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à à nous dire
par exemple l'état de votre patrimoine
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau oui oui oui
mais vous savez à 27 ans à 27 ans il est
quasiment inexistant dire la vérité donc
par conséquent j'ai j'ai pas du tout de
problème avec ça j'ai envoyé évidemment
le document en question qui sera publié
je pense dans les prochains jours dans
les prochains mois c'est c'est pas moi
qui qui gère ça mais mais moi j'ai pas
du tout de difficulté avec ça et je
pense que chacun peut publier son
patrimoine si ça vous paraît
indispensable mais le le véritable
problème c'est de savoir si on
s'enrichit grâce au mandat qui est le
nôtre c'est ça le vrai problème et je
pense que c'est là-dessus que nous
devrions agir en tout cas avoir des vues
allez on envent tout de suite à notre
nouvelle rubrique de Parlement Hebdo
c'est la loupe du
scan avec notre partenaire du Figaro le
scan.fr nous accueillons le rédacteur en
chef de ce site Jim jarassé Jim nactu
encore très chargé cette semaine vous
allez nous décrypter bonjour David
Rachine c'est mois le sénateur frontiste
que l'ex responsable de la communication
numérique du Front national que je vais
interroger aujourd'hui euh je vais
essayer de de de voir avec vous euh
quelle est la la comment la la
communication
euh numérique du Front national a évolué
et notamment ces dernières semaines on a
l'impression que c'est devenu plus
compliqué de gérer toutes les les
expressions numériques des cadres du
Front national j'ai plusieurs exemples
le premier c'est ce tweet de Jean-Marie
Le Pen qui a été publié le 9 janvier il
faut rappeler le contexte c'est le jour
du double assaut àam Martin angouel et
sur sur la porte de Vincen à l'épicerie
cacher il y a ce tweet qui sort sur le
le Twitter de de Jean-Marie Le Pen qui
calme vote Le Pen gardez votre calme
votez le pen c'est une un flagrant délit
de récupération politique est-ce que
vous regrettez ce type de tweet d'abord
moi je suis pas Jean-Marie Le Pen donc
vous poserez la question à Jean-Marie Le
Pen moi ce que je peux vous dire que oui
ça c'est un fait mais ce que je peux
vous dire en tout cas c'est que notre
stratégie sur Internet et et la
stratégie que nous av avion misise en
place dès l'élection présidentielle en
2012 a fonctionné nous sommes les
premiers le premier parti politique sur
Internet nous avons une efficacité
record dans ces domainesl et nous
n'avons pas de difficultés majeur en
l'occurrence ce tweet est-ce qu'il était
dans dans dans la dans une ligne de
communication consciente du Front
national c'était quelque chose de
volontaire sa la ligne de communication
qui a été la nôre c'est celle qui a été
développée par Marine Le Pen pendant
pendant ces semaines ces semaines
difficiles pour notre pays Jean-Marie Le
Pen a sa liberté de ton il est un il est
habitué à en user d'ailleurs il faut
bien le dire et c'est sa responsabilité
mais ce qui est ce qui est certain c'est
que la ligne du mouvement politique la
ligne stratégique l'orientation claire
c'est Marine Le Pen qui la fixe et je
crois qu'elle a eu l'occasion de le
faire et c'était parfaitement clair
autre exemple alors autre exemple cette
vidéo de l'eurodéputé
é choprat dont on parle beaucoup cette
semaine et on va en regarder quelques
extraits tout de suite on nous dit
qu'une majorité de musulmans est
pacifique certes mais une majorité
d'allemand l'été avant 1933 et le
national socialisme allemand une
majorité de Russes de chinois de Kmer
étai Pacifique avant qu'il ne réalise
d'abominables crimes au nom du
communisme Marine Le Pen s'est
désolidarisé d'Emerick choprade en
interdisant au quart du Front national
de diffuser cette vidéo pourtant Marion
maréchal Le Pen s'est fondu d'un petit
tweet pour diffuser cette cette vidéo
alors on a l'impression qu'il y a deux
camps un peu qui se dessinent au sein du
Front national dans quel camp vous
situez-vous je suis pas là pour
commenter le tweet de tel responsable
politique
comis Politi ça prend politique cette
semaine la réalité c'est la suivante
Marine Le Pen a été élue avec 100 % des
voix au dernier congrès c'est elle qui
fixe la ligne c'est elle qui fixe le cap
politique du Front national elle a eu
l'occasion de dire qu'elle était en
désaccord avec une partie en tout cas de
la vision d'emerck choprade euh les
choses sont donc éminemment claires le
Front national sa ligne a été rappelé
par la présidente et une seule Lig et et
il n'y a qu'une seule ligne au Front
national c'est extrêmement clair et moi
je suis en l'occurrence sur la ligne du
front national et seulement toujours sa
place au Front national aujourd'hui mais
encore une fois c'est à lui de nous dire
si et je crois d'ailleurs pouvoir dire
que à 95 % il est d'accord avec la ligne
de Marine Le Pen et avec la ligne
stratégique politique qui est celle de
notre Présidente il faut encore une fois
un petit peu de discipline dans un
mouvement il faut
respecter une forme d' on en parlait
tout à l'heure mais dans un parti
politique c'est valable aussi et donc il
est normal que Marine Le Pen remette de
l'ordre quand c'est nécessaire une
polémique a également éclaté dans votre
ville de Fréjus oui vous avez pris la
décision en décembre je crois de
supprimer l'abonnement de la médiatque a
plusieurs quotidiens nationaux dont
Libération et Le Figaro alors vous
invoquez des choix budgéaires c'est
c'est tout à fait compréhensible et vous
avez le droit en tant que maire de de
faire ça mais vos opposants locaux ont
organisé une une manifestation pour
dénoncé une atteinte au pluralisme de la
presse ou euh est-ce que vous n'avez pas
regretté cette décision après les les
attentats qui ont frappé la la la
rédaction de Charlie non vous savez
d'ailleurs bon un les les adversaires
politiques du Parti socialiste qui
étaient présence sur jour-là était 10 et
l'immense majorité des fréjuciens a bien
compris que c'était pas le maire de
Fréjus qui avait fait ce choix il y
avait un budget acquisition journaux de
11000 € il est passé à 7000 € dans le
cadre des économies j'ai désendetté la
commune qui était la 5è commune la plus
endettée de France de 8 millions dem000
d'euros sur la première année il y a
beaucoup de collectivités peut-être
qu'il ferait bien de s'en inspirer on
est passé donc de 16 160 abonnements à
100 abonnements pour une raison simple
c'est qu'il nous fallait faire des
économies encore une fois et donc la
direction de la bibliothèque a choisi
les les journaux et les magazines qui
étaient les plus cons va se passer vous
remettez le Figaro vous remettez l'ibbé
c'est ceux qui sont les plus consultés
qui ont été conservés maintenant encore
une fois si ça fait plaisir euh au Parti
socialiste ou si ça fait plaisir à un
certain nombre de personnes et s'il faut
remettre le Figaro pour leur faire
plaisir moi je suis une bonne
composition et et mais nous verrons
encore une fois mais si les fré juciens
le réclamament vous savez ils peuvent
aussi les gens du Parti socialiste qui
allaient lire eux libération hein et pas
spécialement le Figaro je pense il
peuvent aussi aller dans un kiosque et
puisqu'ils ont des indemnités d'élu
importantes madame dimeéo est je crois
présidente de commission conseil
régional elle a des indemnité importante
et peut aller soutenir libération et la
presse en allant l'acheter dans un
kiosque ou même en s'abonnant ce qui
serait la porte ouverte merci beaucoup
porte ouverte bon il y a eu une des
conséquences évidemment de ce climat
très lourd c'est les films qui ont été
déprogrammés C derniers jours par des
maires vous êtes Mair on vous demandera
votre avis dans dans un instant c'est le
plus de
l'bdo pour l'un de ces films l'histoire
raconte la conversion d'un jeune
français de tradition musulmane au
catholicisme pour l'autre l'arrivée des
islamistes à tambouou deux films qui ont
été déprogrammés dans certaines villes
c'est é par Simon
Barbar seul du qui me touche c'est
Jésus-Christ le Fils de
Dieu un jeune musulman qui se convertit
au christianisme le sujet est sensible
c'est celui du film l'apôtre réalisé et
produit par cHEYEN Caron un mini budget
50000 € une diffusion plus que discrète
moins de 10 salles en France et pourtant
la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure a vivement conseillé la
déprogrammation du film dans une salle
de cinéma Nant
un risque d'attentat est évoqué la
projection est annulée que sais-tu au
juste de de Jésus qui est-il pour toi
vraiment même message à un cinéma de ne
sur scène mais cette fois-ci la
projection est reportée à la mi-avril
des précautions compréhensibles mais en
contradiction avec les nombreux messages
sur la liberté d'expression distillé
dans la sphère publique depuis les
attentats de Charlie bien loin de la
provocation l'apôtre est un film
foncièrement pacifiste ou peu à peu
catholique et musulmans avancent vers
une compréhension
lui ai éprramm à sur Mar
lecqu a cru que le film sélectionné au
dernier Festival de can faisait
l'apologie du terrorisme peut-être
auraitil d voir l'vre avant car elle en
est tout le
contraire ropédalage du maen est suivi
le fil ser fin une quinzaine de jours
mais escorté d'un débat avec
responsables religieux et associatifs
des précautions qu'il y a quelques
semaines encore auraient semblé bien
superflu vous le maire de Fréjus
seriez-vous prêt à céder à des
intimidations pour déprogrammer un film
non clairement NON je pense que il est
important que la liberté d'expression
soit totale y compris dans le monde
cinématographique néanmoins je peux
comprendre l'inquiétude d'un élu local
qui considère que les conditions de
sécurité ne sont pas réunies et donc
voilà c'est c'est un sujet un petit peu
compliqué mais le le rappel est clair
sur la valeur qu'est la liberté
d'expression liberté d'expression un
petit peu à géométrie variable au sein
du Front national puisque vous-même vous
avez interdit un journaliste de
l'Express d'accéder à une vos
conférences de presse à Fréjus le petit
journal est interdit des congrès
frontistes c'est pas quand même de PO de
mesure la liberté d'expression au sein
du Front national vous savez non non pas
du tout dans la l'immense majorité de
nos réunions tous les journalistes sont
les bienvenus et vous le savez bien
disait certains vous êtes le seul parti
politique à le faire en France non mais
d'abord le petit journal ce ne sont pas
des journalistes
c'est c'est c'est du divertissement et
et quand on voit si vous voulez la
manière qu'ils ont de de nous traiter je
crois que en effet ça n'est pas
acceptable et quand à par exemple le
méia part qu' que nous refusons aussi et
ce sont eux qui avaient choisi de ne pas
traiter Marine Le Pen dans le cadre de
la présidentielle donc c'est un juste
retour des ch exactement merci David
rachn d'avoir commenté avec nous
l'actualité de la semaine merci Michell
très bonne suite des
programmes